انت كتبت عن الاسباب التي يمكن ان تدفع
الحركات
الاسلامويه الى الذهاب الى اوكرانيا
للقتال في صف الاوكران او القتال في صف
الروس واستخدام هذه الحرب كابور التوتر
جديده نحن نعلم ان القاعده استاذنا الفاضل
لدى هذه التنظيمات انهم يتواجدون في بيئه
التوتر في بيئه الفوضى وان لم توجد هذه
البيئه هم يصنعون بيئه التوتر لا وجود لهم
الا في بيئه التوتر ثم القاعده الثانيه
المهمه جدا وهي ان العمل لدى هذه
التنظيمات يسبق التنظيرات الفكريه يعني
انهم يقومون بالاعمال ثم يبحثون عن الدليل
الشرعي الذي يستندون اليه شرعيا وفكريا
وايدولوجيا يعني ليست الفكره سابقه ابدا
العمل ومن ثم هم
توقعت انهم سوف يستغلون هذه الحرب بدايه
لسابق تاريخهم في حرب عام 2014 حينما
قاموا بتشكيل
خليه حرب القرد روسيا نعم نعم حرب نعم
وحاولوا نستغله ذلك يعني اللي هم الهاربين
او السماويين من الشيشان
ثانيا بعض الصفحات التي تناولت هذه الحرب
في بدايتها اولا من ناحيه السعاده والفرح
باندلاع هذه الحرب وثانيا
بالاستناد الى ما قاله ايمن الظواهري في
احد اصداراته بانه يجوز
المشاركه مع الكفار في حرب الكفار الاخرين
طالما ان ذلك ينهك الكافرين يعني يعني هذا
معنى كلام ايمن الظواهري في حديث سابق له
فالاستناد الى ذلك كتدليل على حاله الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه في انه يجوز لكن اسمح